oi gente
você se lembra dessa lâmpada essa
lâmpada incandescente
na casa da gente por muito muito tempo
vocês se lembram da cor dela e essa cor
amarela
pois bem essa lâmpada passou a ser
substituída pela lâmpada fluorescente
pelo fato de ela consumir energia demais
pra gerar luz 90 95% do que ela consome
de energia para gerar calor e não luz
imagina só até brinco que ela na verdade
é uma fonte de calor que a por acaso
também gera luz mas é óbvio que na época
em que ela foi criada ela transformou a
forma de as pessoas viverem
principalmente à noite
mas o fato é que ela foi substituída
pela lâmpada fluorescente porque era a
cor dela se eles lembram que era o pa
imagino que muitos de vocês devem ter
pensado na cor branca
o que é plausível porque quando essa
lâmpada surgiu no mercado ela veio
predominantemente na cor branca e isso
cria um consciente coletivo de que pra
economizar energia precisa mudar a cor
da luz o que não é verdade que o que
deixa de lado uma questão fundamental
que é o impacto que a iluminação causa
na nossa vida o nosso corpo que foi
preparado para a luz natural
aquela luz do sol e quando a gente olha
assim no meio dia está bem branca porque
ela é branca porque ela tem se a luz
vermelha luz amarela luz verde violeta
luz azul
alguém já ouviu falar na luz azul essa é
uma luz fundamental para nós
embora a gente não a perceba com os
nossos olhos ela impacta o nosso corpo e
faz com que estimule a produção de um
hormônio chamado cortisol
esse hormônio ele nos estimula a
atividade é fundamental para o
equilíbrio do nosso relógio biológico
aquilo que tecnicamente a gente chama de
ciclo circadiano que nos faz acordar e
despertar pela manhã e tende a gente
descansar
na parte da noite mas a questão gente é
que essa luz azul
ela não está só na luz natural ela
também está em equipamentos eletrônicos
como algumas lâmpadas como na tela do
nosso computador como na tela do nosso
celular e é por isso que não se
recomenda o uso do celular na cama antes
de dormir
sabe onde isso porque enquanto o seu
corpo está querendo
relaxar para ter um sono de qualidade
o celular está mandando uma mensagem
para ele dizendo produza cortisol produz
um hormônio para atividade e isso impede
você de chegar num sono profundo que é
fundamental para restabelecer sua
energia quem nunca dormiu 89 horas e
ainda acordo alcançado isso a médio
longo prazo gente nos leva a um cansaço
crônico nos aproxima da chance de ter
depressão como augusto cury chama de mal
do século
aumenta a nossa possibilidade de ter
crises de ansiedade
entendendo então o impacto que a luz
causa na nossa vida vamos pensar no lado
psicológico como é que é iluminado o
nosso ambiente de trabalho por exemplo
geralmente assim uma luz branca
homogênea é uma luz propícia para nos
estimular a concentração a produtividade
bacana pra isso
nós temos um comportamento que é mais
impessoal mais racional mais frio muitas
vezes imperativo para dar uma ordem que
inconscientemente agente vincula essa
atmosfera há a necessidade desse
comportamento e isso se torna
extremamente perigoso
quando a gente pega essa iluminação e
remete para a nossa casa
você pode ter um espaço bem tratado
bonito mas quando a gente chega em casa
na primeira informação que a gente
recebe
não é um bom dia boa tarde boa noite é
que o ambiente que eu tô
então quando a gente chega em casa e tem
essa atmosfera a gente tende a manter
aquele comportamento em pessoal o que
aumenta a chance de impaciência nos
nossos relacionamentos que nossa esposa
com nossos filhos
imagina você chegar em casa como esse
ambiente e ele está iluminado dessa
forma imediatamente você recebe uma
mensagem que diz é um ambiente familiar
é um ambiente de afeto é um ambiente de
amor onde eu posso me desarmar
transporta isso para o seu quarto
imagina você chegar no seu quarto e
observar seu marido sua esposa em um
ambiente iluminado assim percebo qual
mais gostoso e até romântico fica se
tiver um ambiente como
e não só quando a gente estiver com
alguém mas até se você estiver sozinho
em um momento como o banho que é
objetivo para lá vai para se lavar
ao invés de iluminar simplesmente de uma
forma objetiva da licença objetiva como
essa a gente pode iluminar de uma forma
mais agradável como essa e fazer com que
o banho também seja um momento de
descanso visual de descanso da mente
reflexão talvez esse a luz impacta em
casa desse jeito imagina por exemplo no
consultório de um psicólogo
geralmente os ambientes iluminados assim
uma luz geral central em um ambiente
como esse qualquer paciente qualquer
pessoa se sente observada analisada
isso é terrível para um tratamento como
esse percebo que com uma luminária zinha
simples barata colocado no canto da
poltrona
você pode ter um ambiente como esse
muito mais propício para a pessoa se
abrir muito mais amigável isso a
qualidade de vida tanto profissional
quanto para o paciente porque o
tratamento ele avança ele se acelera e
para despertar a curiosidade de vocês se
lembram dessa luminária zinha aliás
antes disso quero fazer uma experiência
imagina e observem esse ambiente que
está iluminado dessa forma ele está
propício pra vocês prestarem atenção na
mensagem que está sendo falado aqui
imagina se esse ambiente fosse nominal
desse jeito
várias pessoas se ajeitar na cadeira e
pode voltar é para que vocês fiquem mais
confortáveis e prestem atenção nessa
mensagem que é pra ser importante
e uma curiosidade imagina essa luminária
que bonitinha que a gente compra e
feirinhas por aí
ela existe uma forma de colocar dentro
da arquitetura desse jeito como o céu
estrelado e teve uma situação em que a
mãe precisava trocar fralda da filha de
um ano e meio ele e ela estava chorando
não conseguia se dispor a quilo quando
entrar num ambiente como esse
a criança ficou sozinha
nessa hora a mãe pode colocar a criança
em cima da cama e trocar a fralda com
facilidade
isso trouxe qualidade de vida tanto para
a mãe quanto para a criança tornou menos
traumático aquele momento
quem tem filho filho aqui pequeno sabe
quantas vezes é trabalhoso trocar uma
fralda
agora a gente por mais que a gente não
usa uma tecnologia tão criativa
a gente tem uma informação que pode nos
nos fazer decidir pela melhor lâmpada
quando a gente olha um catálogo ela pode
ter escrito assim a temperatura de co
ela pode estar textualmente escrita como
quente ou fria ou numericamente como
3000k ou 6500k com essa informação a
gente pode decidir se chegar numa loja e
pegar uma embalagem está escrito lá por
exemplo os fria é aquela branca ou então
ela pode estar numericamente 6500k com
essa informação a gente traz que essa
decisão não é papo de especialista
o especialista não sabe o que meio que
mais nos agrada
nós podemos escolher entre uma luz mais
quente uma luz mais fria entendendo que
a iluminação não tá aqui só para
iluminar mas ela de fato transforma as
nossas experiências
adriano
[Aplausos]